>>Female Presenter: Hello.
Thank you so much for coming to what is the
latest in our political Fireside Chats.
Some of you may recall, but in 2010 we hosted
a number of candidates and campaigns on campus.
And we think this is a real value to Googlers
to hear what's going on in our home state.
So this is the latest in the political Fireside
Chats for 2012.
We will be offering the other side of this
issue to come to campus and have the same
opportunity to speak to Googlers.
And to hear questions from you all.
And with that, I'm gonna hand this over to
Alan.
>>Alan: So thanks for coming.
I appreciate it.
You know, this is an issue that I think sometimes
there's an abstract issue.
You know, you think about the death penalty
and it's kind of somebody else's problem.
It's on the pages of the news.
And you know, you see it that way.
But it's not personal.
And I feel like one of the things that's missing
from political debate in general, but in this
topic in particular, is the personal side
on some of these issues.
And so I've been talking to Natasha, and full
disclosure, I support this cause.
I support the SAFE ballot initiative.
I'm one of the funders of that initiative.
But in the course of that conversation, I've
learned a lot about the issues.
And one of the things that she and I talked
about was, you know, would it be possible
to host an event here.
Would it be possible for us to learn a little
bit more about the issues and the impact of
those issues?
And she did something which was fantastic.
Which she actually just put together a panel
here.
Of people on, you know, two people that were
on Death Row, that actually through a long
and I'm sure arduous process, that they'll
tell you about, were exonerated.
And also a former warden at San Quentin that
can show you that perspective.
And of course Natasha's working very hard
on a ballot initiative that she'll tell you
about as well.
But the main thing that I want to get out
of this morning is to just personalize it.
It's not an abstract issue.
It's a very specific one.
The consequences of our decisions are enormous.
Probably the single most enormous consequence
that any society or decision can make.
And I feel like, because of that it's really
important for us as individuals and as citizens
to know what we're getting into.
And what we have got into.
So with that, I wanted to turn it over.
Do you want to start with introductions here?
>>Natasha: Sure.
My name is Natasha Minsker.
I am the campaign manager for the SAFE California
Act.
>>Jeannie: My name is Jeannie Woodford.
I'm the Warden on the panel.
But currently I'm the executive director of
Death Penalty Focus.
And I'm the proponent of the initiative to
replace the Death Penalty in California.
>>Nathan: My name is Nathan Fields.
And I'm the chairmen of Witness to Innocence
compensation committee.
I spent a total of 18 years in prison.
11 and a half on death row for a crime I didn't
commit.
>>Randy: I'm Randy Steidl.
And I'm president of the broad of directors
of Witness to Innocence.
And I spent almost 18 years in prison and
12 on death row for a crime I didn't commit.
>>Alan: So let's start with you.
I think you know, let's just start at the
beginning of your story.
>>Randy: Well first off, I would like to thank
Death Penalty Focus and SAFE California.
And the Google policy makers group.
For inviting me.
Giving me this opportunity to explain exactly
what happened to me with this barbaric system
that Illinois had in place.
In 1986, in the small town of Paris, Illinois,
there was a gruesome murder of a young newlywed
couple.
And Paris was such a small town you could
imagine how it shocked the whole community.
Four weeks before these murders had happened,
I had reported the local state's attorney
to the FBI for drug distribution and protecting
drug distribution in that small town.
And it was three days after these murders
that there was a knock on my door and wanted
me to come downtown for questioning.
I cooperated fully with the police.
I had a brother that was a Illinois State
Police officer.
I had a grandfather that was a Deputy Sheriff.
So I believed that you should cooperate with
authority.
I went down and gave them my step by step
whereabouts.
Who I was with.
What times I was there.
And I was released.
Seven months later there was another knock
on the door.
Five police officers come into my home with
guns drawn.
Throwed me down on the floor.
And arrested me and booked me for a double
murder I didn't commit.
And you can only imagine the pain and the
suffering that I felt when my little brother
came to the jail.
Slammed a [indistinct] down in front of the
holding cell, and said "Well, I've talked
to the prosecutor and the lead detective,
and they said, if you cooperate they won't
seek the death penalty."
And I can't repeat the exact words I told
him that night in jail.
Wouldn't be appropriate.
He got mad and screamed at me.
And kicked the stool across the office floor
and screamed "They don't arrest people that
aren't guilty."
Now you can imagine anybody saying that.
But my own brother said they don't arrest
people that aren't guilty.
My case was rife with corruption, political
influence.
The State had two alleged eye witnesses that
said they were present at the crime scene.
But yet neither one of them saw each other.
This young newlywed couple was just viciously
stabbed over 50 times.
And their home was set on fire.
I went from the comforts in my home to Death
Row in 97 days.
That's unheard of today.
But through the years there was no physical
evidence.
No forensic evidence.
No DNA.
Nothing linking me to this crime but a town
drunk, who said he was an eyewitness.
And a mentally ill, violently mentally ill
woman.
Who claimed to be present.
And actually held the woman down while me
and my co-defendant stabbed her to death.
Yet she was free to go home after giving that
statement.
Can you imagine?
My appeals process in the state of Illinois
was nothing more than an exercise in futility.
Because there is nothing to doubt.
There was two alleged eyewitnesses, right?
Even though their stories were not credible.
And didn't corroborate each other.
I spent over 12 years on Death Row before
I finally got some relief through the state
of Illinois because my attorney who was incompetent,
didn't put on any mitigation at sentencing.
And I ended up with the Death Penalty.
Finally I ended up with life without parole.
I had one appeal left.
It was a Federal court.
And after 14 years there was finally enough
publicity to embarrass the Illinois State
Police, who assigned an investigator to review
the case.
Hoping he would just rubber stamp it.
And this cop didn't do that.
He was one of those Serpico type police officers.
That was a search for the truth, to him.
He tried five times to reopen a case.
Said "You got two innocent men sitting here."
He said "I'm trying to bring closure to the
murder victim's family members and address
this corruption and wrongdoing within the
police department and the state's attorney's
office."
He was denied five times to reopen the case.
They said the case was too politically sensitive.
But if it had not been for this police officer,
at the very least I'd be spending the rest
of my life in prison.
Because his reports and his investigation
combined with my federal habeas corpus petition
in federal court is what convinced the federal
judge to either release or have the state
retry me in 120 days.
So after 17 years, three months, and three
weeks, May 28, 2004, I was released.
And it was like being reborn.
Into the arms of my family and my children.
Alan?
>>Alan: That's quite a story.
So, also from Illinois, also in the same system.
>>Nathan: Right.
>>Alan: Please tell your story.
>>Nathan: Mm.
My story begins in 1985.
I was the manager of a Southside Chicago building.
I had did what I always do every morning.
Which is go down the street, to McDonald's
and get a cup of coffee.
As I was going to get the cup of coffee, the
police pulled me over.
I was not speeding.
I was not doing anything wrong.
They told me to show some ID.
Which I did.
Upon showing the ID, the policeman went back
to his car.
When he came back, he had his gun out.
And two other squad cars, unmarked, had pulled
up.
And they all pulled their guns out.
They told me "Keep your hands on the car."
I told 'em "I'm not gonna move.
I'm not gonna move."
'Cause they had the guns aiming directly at
me.
They put me in the squad car.
One of them got in my car.
And we all drove to the police station.
When we got to the police station, one of
the cops told me, "Hey, Nate, we'll see you
in 40 years."
I really didn't understand what he was talking
about.
'Cause I was trying to figure why did they
even bring me to the police station.
While I was there, the police did not ask
me any questions about any crime.
They didn't interrogate me or try to get a
confession or nothing.
They just, were just saying, "You goin' down."
So when I went for arraignment a couple of
days later, I was shocked when I appeared
before the judge, and he read off that I was
charged with a double murder.
Make a long story short.
My trial began before Judge Thomas Malone.
I went to trial, the case was very weak.
Because I was arrested 13 months after it
happened.
There was no physical evidence.
No DNA evidence.
The sole suspect that they was looking for
was a person that was 18 years old to 20.
Light skinned black male.
At that time, I was 31 years old.
When I was arrested.
And as you see, I'm not a light skinned black
male.
Mm.
That to the side, I went before this judge
and he found me guilty.
Upon finding me guilty, I really thought that
the judge was just prejudiced against me.
And I had a co-defendant as well.
And I really thought the judge was just prejudiced
against me.
But I didn't know what happened.
But I know that evidence did not prove me
guilty.
It was about five high school students that
testified at my trial.
That I couldn't have been the person.
And it was only one eyewitness who claimed
that he saw the crime from over 150 feet away,
playing baseball.
He found me guilty.
And upon finding me guilty, we went to the
sentencing hearing.
At the sentencing hearing, the very witness,
the one witness that pointed me out, said
that he had lied.
And that the police had coached him to say
that I was the one.
And that they had manipulated the lineup.
That to the side, the judge still would not
give me a new trial.
Or stave off my death sentence.
So I was sent to Death Row.
I was found, well I was given the death penalty,
I went to Death Row.
Death Row, let me tell you something about
it.
It's like hell on earth.
When I got there, lot of guys that tried to
help me before I left.
They was either executed.
Or they had lost they mind.
The place is so restrictive.
You're in a cell five by eight.
You're led around with a dog chain.
Handcuffs.
Shackles.
Everywhere you go.
You're allowed out the cell one hour per day.
The stress that I saw on Death Row was so
overwhelming.
To see so many men I just couldn't believe
that everyone was under a death sentence.
Individuals started losin' they mind.
It was nothin' to hear prisoners lay there
at night, talkin' to imaginary figures.
Talkin' to their children.
Talkin' to their wives.
Talkin' to anyone.
Just talkin'.
Hearing prisoners yellin' out in the middle
of the night.
Seein' prisoners who, a few days ago they
was callin' you by your name.
Now you come by their cell, they don't even
know you.
They have lost they mind.
I saw prisoners who, they hadn't combed they
hair in 13 years.
They hadn't brushed they teeth 13 years.
They hadn't tooken a shower in years.
The cell smelled like a lion's den.
The guards would always, when the brass come
on the unit, they would go in and clean these
prisoner's cell out.
And try to deodorize it.
So that the brass wouldn't see what was goin'
on.
Or the visitors that was comin' to the prison.
While I was on Death Row, I was there for
11 executions of men who I knew.
I had the unopportunity to meet one of Illinois'
most noted serial killer, John Wayne Gacy.
Who I met right as I came into the door.
And we had a little situation that developed.
And the guards wouldn't let us come near each
other anymore after we had a little incident.
But that to the side, what happened for me
was, one day I was reading the newspaper.
And I saw in the newspaper, they was talkin'
about my judge who had sentenced me to death.
And then the article said that he had been
indicted for takin' bribes in murder cases.
And he had taken a bribe on my very case.
Um, when I read this I just fell to my knees
and I started prayin'.
What had happened, the judge had taken a bribe
from my co-defendant's attorney to throw the
case.
My co-defendant's attorney had been corrupt
and had bribed the judge on other cases.
I knew nothin' about the bribe.
When the FBI came into the courtroom and was
sittin' on the rows watchin' the trial, and
the bailiffs told the judge that the FBI was
in the courtroom.
He knew that they was up on the bribe.
And they were.
They had tapped his phone.
In a desperate attempt to cover it up, he
gave the money back to my co-defendant's attorney
and he had convicted me to cover it up.
At this present time, this judge has served
13 years in prison for doin' this.
He is the first and the most corrupt judge
in American history to be found guilty of
sendin' individuals to Death Row to cover
up a bribe.
At that point, I got a new trial.
I was found not guilty at my new trial.
I represented myself on my certificate of
innocence before the chief judge of Cooke
County.
Against the very prosecutors who was tryin'
to send me back to Death Row.
And I won.
A certificate of innocence is a legal document
that declares that legally you were innocent.
After that, I filed the largest lawsuit in
Illinois history for a wrongful conviction.
Thank you.
>>Alan: So, Jeannie.
You've seen it from the inside as well.
On the other side of the cell block.
Can you tell me your story?
>>Jeannie: Yes.
Thank you so much for having me here.
And your stories are just so touching.
It's just so difficult to believe that in
America we have to worry about issues like
this.
But we do.
So I started at San Quentin State Prison in
1978, two weeks after graduating from Sonoma
State University with a degree in Criminal
Justice.
I started as a correctional officer.
At that time Death Row had about eight inmates
on it.
I stayed at San Quentin for over 26 years.
Promoting up through the ranks until I became
the Warden in 1999.
And during that time, I saw Death Row grow
from the eight inmates that were there when
I started to where it is today.
We have over 725 people on Death Row in the
state of California.
It's the largest Death Row in the United States.
When I became the warden in 1999.
Let's just say, I feel like I've grown up
with the death penalty, 'cause I've seen it
from every point of view and from every position.
Working within a prison.
Having worked on Death Row as a correctional
officer.
As a counselor.
As a captain.
And then I became the chief deputy and then
finally the warden.
But when I became the warden in 1999, it became
my responsibility to carry out executions.
And so I've been involved in four executions.
I've always been morally opposed to the death
penalty.
But when you're the warden, you tell yourself
it is your job to carry out the laws on behalf
of the citizens of the state of California.
But then I want you to think about that.
What is it that we ask of public servants?
So I describe it this way.
As the warden, you get up 30 to 60 days prior
to a scheduled execution.
You put on your clothes and you get ready
to go to work.
You hug your husband goodbye.
You tell your children to have a great day
at school.
You get in your car.
And for me I drove the 28 miles to San Quentin,
knowing that I was going there to carry out
an execution.
And as the warden it's not only your job to
carry out an execution, it's your job to lead
your staff through that process.
And staff are involved in this process for
many reasons.
But most people believe that they're there
carrying out the laws as the citizens expect
them to do.
So you end up the night of the execution,
and you see it from every point of view.
You see the victim's family members come to
the execution.
The inmate's family and their legal team.
You watch the faces of your staff as you're
carrying out that execution.
And then after each execution, someone on
my staff would say something like "Did we
improve public safety in California today?"
And we never answered that question because
we knew the answer was "No."
And so you start to think about this from
a public policy point of view.
And you look at the cost of executions.
The state of California spent four billion
dollars on the death penalty since 1978.
Four billion dollars.
We've carried out 13 executions.
That means that each execution was over 300
million dollars.
And then because I've spent over 30 years
in criminal justice I've really studied the
science of criminal justice.
And I believe I know what works.
And what really works to keep us safe is to
spend our resources solving crime.
And in the state of California, 46 percent
of homicides and 56 percent of reported rapes
go unsolved each year in this state.
And we know what makes us safer is having
more police on the streets.
And yet, in California today, many communities
are removing police from, because of our economic
crisis.
And so, I am the proponent of this initiative
because I believe in public safety.
And I believe we can use our resources in
a much more productive way that improves public
safety in the state of California.
And keeps our children and our communities
safer.
Thank you.
>>Alan: Thank you.
Natasha.
>>Natasha: Thank you Alan.
Thank you very much to everyone at Google
for having us here today.
And I just have to say, it's really an honor
to sit on the stage with these individuals.
And to work with folks like this.
Who have been through so much.
And bring so much personal experience to this.
As Alan said, this is a personal issue for
people.
And it's easy to think that the Death Penalty
doesn't touch our lives.
It touches many people's lives.
And you've heard some of their stories.
And I'm sure you will have questions for them.
I am the campaign manager for the SAFE California
Act.
The SAFE California Act is an initiative that
will be on the November ballot this year in
California.
The initiative does three things.
It will replace the Death Penalty with life
without possibility of parole as the maximum
punishment for murder.
It requires every person convicted of murder
to work in prison and pay restitution to the
victim's compensation fund.
And it will take a portion of the money that
we are going to save by replacing the Death
Penalty and direct it to local law enforcement
for the purpose of increasing the rate at
which we solve rape and murder cases here
in California.
The SAFE California Act will make sure that
we never execute an innocent person here in
California.
You have just heard Randy and Nate's stories
from Illinois.
These problems happen here in California as
well.
Hundreds of people have been wrongfully convicted
in California of serious crimes.
Many of them have been wrongfully convicted
of murder.
People like Franky Carrillo, who works with
us on this campaign.
Franky was just 16 years old when he was wrongfully
convicted of a murder.
It took 20 years for him to prove his innocence.
These two men served, themselves, almost two
decades in prison for crimes they did not
commit.
These mistakes are serious and as Jeannie
said, they continue to happen.
The only way we can prevent the execution
of an innocent person in California is if
we replace the Death Penalty with the SAFE
California Act this November.
The initiative will also save California over
100 million dollars each year.
It's surprising to many people, but the Death
Penalty is enormously expensive.
Much more expensive than the alternative of
life without possibility of parole.
And that's because the entire process is more
complicated.
In fact it's a double trial process.
A Death Penalty trial involves stage one where
you decide if the person actually committed
the crime.
Just like every other criminal trial.
But then there's a whole second trial where
we decide whether the person gets death or
life without parole.
Two trials requires two lawyers on the defense
team.
Two investigators.
The prosecution team is even larger.
It takes months just to select a jury in a
Death Penalty case.
And the judge has to be specially qualified
as well.
This is all just to get to the death sentence.
After that, there's literally 25 years of
appeals in California Death Penalty cases.
25 years of court processes and more attorneys
that we pay for.
And one of the most surprising things is that
the housing in Death Row cases here in California
is more expensive than life without possibility
of parole.
If those 724 people who are now on Death Row
were sentenced to life without parole instead,
we would actually save 30 million dollars
a year just in the extra housing costs alone.
You all know that California is in the midst
of a terrible economic crisis and that we
are facing terrible budget cuts.
Just today in fact, the governor signed a
new budget with deeper cuts to social services.
Cuts to Healthy Families.
I actually can't believe we live in a state
where we are cutting a program called Healthy
Families that gives health insurance to poor
children.
But we just cut that program.
Because we just don't have the money we need
for the things we need.
And meanwhile we waste over 100 million dollars
a year, every year, on a terribly broken death
penalty in this state.
That's why we need the SAFE California Act.
And the initiative for a three year period
will direct 30 million dollars a year to local
law enforcement.
Specifically to increase the rate at which
we solve rape and murder cases.
I was shocked when I learned that 46 percent
of murders go unsolved and 56 percent of reported
rapes go unsolved every year in California.
And behind those numbers are real people.
And real families.
People like Lorrain Taylor, Lorrain Taylor's
twin sons were murdered in Oakland.
Two kids in college.
Their car broke down.
They were on the side of the road trying to
fix it.
In the wrong neighborhood.
And they were shot and killed in a drive by
shooting.
The person who killed them has never been
caught.
Lorraine Taylor has a group that she works
with.
Other mothers and fathers who have lost children
to gun violence.
And every week she goes down to the homicide
department in Oakland and she asks about their
cases.
And every day, every week, when she meets
with the head of Homicide, he sits and says
to her, "I'm sorry Ms. Taylor.
I don't have anything for you on this case.
" And she says "What about this case?" and
he says "I'm sorry Ms. Taylor.
We have no leads in that case either."
It was Lorraine who told me that the Oakland
police department couldn't afford to have
a fingerprint analyst.
And so for a while they stopped collecting
fingerprints.
Those are the kinds of basic public safety
needs that are not getting met right now in
California.
As we lay off police officers and cut core
services to our law enforcement.
So by ending the waste on the death penalty,
we are going to be able to redirect money
to our most important needs like our kid's
schools.
And for three years, we are gonna direct funds
directly to local law enforcement to meet
the most important public safety need in California.
Which is catching the killers and the rapists
who are still walking free in our streets.
That is why we call this the SAFE California
Act.
Because this is about making California a
safe place.
Protecting the innocent from wrongful execution.
And protecting every one of our families from
the people who are out there who could commit
harm.
And so we are gonna ask you to support the
SAFE California Act this November as a really
important step for making California the kind
of place we all wanna live in.
>>Alan: Great.
Thank you.
So you guys please, ask questions.
You know, it'd be great to get your impressions.
But I'll start here.
Lemme just tell you, I'm, people ask me why
I donated to this particular cause.
And it really came down to one thing for me.
Is that our standard for guilt and innocence
is beyond a reasonable doubt.
And that's a perfectly fine standard.
I think that's a standard where you know,
for somebody that's shoplifting.
That seems like a perfectly reasonable standard.
But to put this man to death?
I don't know.
It just, for me, doesn't feel like that's
the standard that we need.
And that we as Californians would feel comfortable
with that standard being applied in these
kinds of cases.
And I think it would be a harder problem to
change the whole standards associated with
it.
And obviously it's also a problem in my mind,
of how wildly diverging that standard has
been applied, based on ethnicity.
Based on what state you're in.
based on prosecutors.
Based on other things.
And I can't sit back and have the feeling
that we as Californians, and we as Americans
are being fair.
And that we're doing the right thing.
And the money is obviously important too.
But I feel like, you know, the basic fairness
of the system is what I worry about most.
Go ahead, please.
Ask your question.
>>Female #1: Well thank you for coming today.
I'm actually somebody who's gone back and
forth on the issue.
I fully supported the death penalty, and then
completely against it.
And I can't seem to really fully 100 percent
decide on which way to go.
I think my issue is more a fear of people
like Charles Manson and John Wayne Gacy, and
people who get life in prison, and become,
you know.
Even without the possibility of parole, a
judgment down the line from the Supreme Court
can say "Oh, this new judgment says that these
people can be let off."
And then a new wave of appeals happen, and
people like that may be set free.
I mean, that's an extreme example.
But I think that's where a fear of mine lies.
Why I've gone back and forth on that.
So, I, don't, I understand the rationale behind
it.
But the emotional side of me, I can't seem
to let that fear go.
And I think as the more cases you see of serial
killers coming up, and I am completely ashamed
of the legal system what happened to you two
and stuff.
And I know it actually happens often.
At the same time, I have to kind of look at
my safety as well.
And my family members.
So, how do you kind of tackle that issue when
you're going out and you're trying to convince
people that this is the right thing to do?
>>Randy: Can I address that?
>>Alan: Sure, and I think there's, I actually
had this conversation with Natasha a while
back.
And I think this is a core issue and I'm glad
you brought it up right at the beginning.
>>Randy: You know, I, like you, come from
a conservative family.
My granddad was a Deputy Sheriff.
My brother was State Police.
And I used to see those people being put in
handcuffs, drug across the TV screen.
And "Yeah, they look guilty to me, and they're
being charged with child rape and murder.
Yeah, they need to hang 'em."
That's before I realized, I was naive to the
system.
And most of us are.
Because we all grew up watching Dragnet.
And Mayberry RFD.
And all those shows that show a moral to the
story at the end.
OK?
That's Hollywood.
But that has given us blind allegiance to
these people that are in the criminal justice
system.
The judges.
Officer Friendly with the shiny badge that
gets up there and takes the oath of office.
The prosecutor who says "The people, your
honor.
Ladies and gentlemen, the people."
You see, it's this blind allegiance that the
criminal justice system makes no mistakes.
That has affected all the people.
They don't want you to think there's any chink
in their armor.
Because we know the banking industry's flawed.
We know the medical industry is flawed.
Our government is corrupt.
But they don't want you to think the criminal
justice system is.
It's that blind allegiance that put 139 men
and one woman, on Death Row in this country.
Now the 140 of us, we're the very fortunate
ones, the lucky ones.
The ones that college kids are resources outside
the judicial system, helped expose the truth
and free 'em.
How many others weren't as fortunate as me
and Nate.
Settin' here.
That's because you have a system in place,
a life and death system.
It's an irreversible punishment.
And as Nate so eloquently always says, it's
the human factor.
Those judges.
Those prosecutors.
These defense lawyers.
They're not some god.
They are flesh and blood humans.
Who whether intentionally, or just an honest
mistake, make mistakes because they're human.
And jurors oftentimes convict people just
to be safe.
>>Alan: So let me go back to Natasha and I.
And Jeannie, I think, also have it but to
get to the point of what are the chances of
somebody actually coming out, given life,
a guilty person coming out after life without
parole?
>>Natasha: Let's ask the warden.
>>Jeannie: So a person serving life without
possibility of parole has no opportunity to
be released unless they're able to prove themself
innocent.
That's the only way.
And the only way that law could be changed
in the state of California is to go back to
the voters.
If the voters wanted to change it.
And I think that's virtually impossible.
And then you mentioned Charlie Manson.
So I do wanna tell you about Charlie Manson.
Charlie Manson isn't on Death Row because
the US Supreme Court overturned the death
penalty.
And at that point in time when they did that,
life without possibility of parole was not
a punishment available in California.
It is now a punishment available in California.
And no one gets out who is serving life without
possibility of parole unless they prove themself
innocent.
And we do have one individual, Obie Anthony,
who also works for Death Penalty Focus as
a justice advocate, who was serving life without
possibility of parole and he was exonerated.
Now he could have easily been on Death Row.
But the fact that he was serving life without
possibility of parole allowed him the opportunity
to prove his innocence and he did.
>>Natasha: And I'm really glad you brought
that up and asked that question.
'cause I do think for a lot of people, that's
the core issue here.
Is everyone wants to have safe families.
And how do you guarantee that we're gonna
have safety in our communities in California.
Just yesterday we had an event in Los Angeles
with victims and murder victim family members
who support the SAFE California Act.
There are now over 400 murder victim family
members who have endorsed the initiative.
One of the speakers yesterday is a woman named
Rose.
Rose was raped when she was 22 years old by
a serial killer.
The serial killer actually killed five women.
She is one of two women who survived his brutal
assault.
And as a 22 year old woman, she knew she had
to do everything possible to make sure he
never hurt another woman again.
And she actually testified against him in
three trials.
Until he was sentenced to death twice.
That's how committed she was to making sure
that he would never hurt anyone.
That was 28 years ago.
He still sits on Death Row.
And the appeals process continues.
And Rose now supports the SAFE California
Act.
Because she has realized that actually the
best way to ensure that he never hurts someone
else again, and that California communities
are safe, is with life without possibility
of parole.
She knows that if he is sentenced to life
without parole, he will never get out.
He will actually be forced to work in prison.
Which he doesn't now.
He will pay into the victim's compensation
fund.
And it will put an end to the appeals.
Which have literally tortured her for 28 years.
She has seen that in fact, the death penalty
is actually really just helping him.
Because he has lawyers.
And he has special privileges by being on
Death Row.
And what she wants is to forget about him.
What she wants is for the money that's being
spent on his case to go into things like violence
prevention and treatment.
So that people like him aren't made.
Aren't created.
Don't come to be in California anymore.
She was just one of the speakers.
Another woman who was with us yesterday is
Nova Reeves.
Her mother was killed by a serial killer in
Washington State.
She was 16 years old.
For over ten years she didn't know.
They didn't know where her mother was.
They didn't know.
It took ten years to even solve the crime.
And the killer, that serial killer is serving
life without possibility of parole.
And she described how that for her, was a
moment that let her move on with her life.
This was sort of closure.
There will never be closure.
You cannot close the hole in your heart.
She'll never get her mother back.
Rose will never get her youth back.
But they can be freed from the criminal justice
system.
In a sense of life without parole guarantees
safety for the community.
It means dangerous people will never get out.
But it also lets us shift our resources to
what we really need to do.
Which is actually catching more killers and
rapists who literally walk free right now.
So this initiative is supported by victims
who have been through the worst possible experiences.
Law enforcement who have seen the system firsthand.
As well as innocent people who know that we
can always make a mistake.
>>Alan: Please, go ahead.
>>Female #2: Do you see any positive trends
in other states of overturning the death penalty.
And why do you think this is, I mean I know
state's rights issues, but why isn't' it a
federal issue as well?
>>Natasha: So I'll answer the second one first.
And then I'm actually going to ask Randy and
Nate to describe their work in other states.
So the death penalty is enacted state by state.
Each state makes a decision about whether
they wanna have the death penalty on their
books.
And as of now, we have 17 states that actually
have chosen to use life without parole instead
of the death penalty.
And it's not a federal issue in the sense
that you couldn't pass a federal law that
would say to a state "You can't have the death
penalty."
That the states have the right to determine
their own criminal laws.
The only way the issue can be addressed on
a federal level of the entire country would
be through a US Supreme Court decision.
As Jeannie mentioned, there was actually a
period where the US Supreme Court threw out
the death penalty for the entire country.
But then they allowed new death penalty laws
in 1976 that they thought were gonna fix the
problems.
We know 34 years later that we have all the
same problems that we did before.
It's clear that the Supreme Court will not
rule, not get rid of the death penalty across
the entire country until enough states on
their own have changed their laws.
At a certain point the Supreme Court may say
"Enough states have done away with the death
penalty that the rest of the country has to."
But we're not at that point yet.
So I know that Randy and Nate have been really
active in other states.
So maybe you could talk about the importance
of what's going on there.
>>Randy: Well Witness to Innocence has worked
in the last five states that have abolished
the death penalty.
And I worked in New Mexico, Connecticut, Illinois,
and we've worked in Maryland.
We've worked in Wisconsin to keep it from
coming back.
And I believe that each state is different.
On their approach to why they should do away
with the death penalty.
Illinois, for example, was the mistakes that
they've made.
They had to acknowledge it.
There was 160 men on Death Row and 20 of us
were actually innocent.
Now, you wouldn't get on an airplane if there
was 20 chances in 160 it was gonna crash.
But yet, the death penalty had crashed years
before they put a moratorium in place.
And years before they abolished it.
And I think it's those mistakes and that cost.
Each state works on a different approach.
And if you could educate the people about
the death penalty, the millions of dollars
that they will save.
Like California, for instance.
It couldn't be any better example.
28 years of appeals.
Now, do you think capital qualified defense
lawyers and a prosecutors wanna see the death
penalty abolished?
No. you know why?
It's a cash cow for 'em.
It's nothing more than a stimulus package
that the tax payers are payin' the bill.
When you can give somebody life without parole,
and this is just my own personal opinion.
Because of being on Death Row.
And then as opposed to life without parole.
When you gotta deal with 1000 more violent.
More hate, more rage.
That there was times, had they rolled that
gurney by my cell, I'd have buckled myself
on it.
Most people have no idea the horrors of maximum
security penitentiary life.
And to me, being executed would have been
early release.
It's a miserable existence.
At least when you have life without parole,
you don't risk the possibility of executing
an innocent person.
Because you can release an innocent person
from prison.
You can't release him from the grave.
And Nate and I are perfect examples of that.
>>Alan: Good.
>>Nathan: I wanna say something' on the first
young lady that spoke about the innocence
factor.
My position when it comes to the death penalty
is primarily the human factor.
And that is, we all make mistakes.
We do it all the time.
We can be feeding the baby with a bottle and
we take the nipple and it hits the baby's
chin.
Mistake.
We can make a wrong turn.
One person can get it wrong.
12 people can get it wrong.
100 people can make an honest mistake.
We see it in baseball games.
The player slide into the second base.
The umpire says "He's out."
On first review, he really was safe.
That man can come out the dugout, and go back
to second base.
But you can't bring a man back from the graveyard.
And that's it right there.
You don't want that innocence factor there.
That you know that we all susceptible to.
No matter how much we might wanna deny it.
It is so true.
We make mistakes.
And who wanna be a mistake?
Thank you.
>>Alan: Thanks.
So one thing I wanted to, uh, are you comin'
up?
Go ahead.
>>Female #3: So, it's clear to me that ballot
initiatives in California are very hotly contested.
And I'm interested to know a little bit about
what you anticipate the opposition is against
this bill?
How strong it will be.
How much funding there is.
To oppose it.
Just tell us a little bit more about that.
>>Natasha: Sure, so the main opposition is
the California District Attorney's Association.
And they are currently only a little bit active.
We haven't seen a lot of activity from the
opposition.
But that's actually pretty typical for ballot
initiatives.
The real heat of the campaign will happen
in the fall.
It's a little bit hard to predict how much
money the other side will have.
We are facing a big filing deadline of June
30th when all of the political campaigns have
to do their disclosures about how much money
they have in the bank.
So we'll have a little bit more information
about that.
But honestly, we really won't know until the
fall, how much money the opposition will have.
And how much money our campaign will have.
I can tell you kind of just to give you a
sense of scale, this is not going to be the
biggest spending initiative fight this year
in November.
In California.
There are, we're looking at initiatives on
the ballot related to taxes, and union dues,
those issues we are expecting each side to
spend 40 million dollars or more in those
campaigns.
Our goal for our campaign is much smaller.
But we believe that we know from the polling,
I can tell you, that the California voters
support this initiative.
A majority of California voters are on our
side.
And so we are hopeful that with not as many
millions as you'll see in those other fights,
that we'll be able to get our message to the
key voters in California.
And really do view this as our moment when
we will win this initiative in California.
>>Alan: So, I want to, go ahead.
Come on.
My goal is not to ask any questions.
You know?
So if you guys don't do it then you're gonna
be forced with my questions.
>>Male #1: I'll try to help you.
Yeah.
I just have a quick question.
I'm wondering if the two gentlemen that were
on Death Row can go into a little bit more
detail about what it's like for the experience
of being on Death Row, versus life in parole?
Because I think, financially it makes a lot
of sense to me.
And I'm wondering what it's actually like
if you're accused, experientially, in prison.
>>Nathan: Well.
[sighs] Death Row is, I mean, when you're
somewhere that you know you's not supposed
to be, for somethin' that you didn't do, you're
not comfortable at all.
If you're in prison, doin' a life sentence,
and you there, you there because you supposed
to be there for somethin' that you did, it's
a entirely different mentality.
So Death Row, it creates this stress, it creates
tension, every single day that can really
just cause your mind to just break in half.
So to speak.
You get news from your daughter that she's
hurt.
Or that her birthday is comin' up.
And you can't attend.
You get news like I did, that my mother had
died of a heart attack.
Right in the middle of tryin' to hold my everything
together.
It just totally different.
And you're there.
On the yard.
With a friend.
Who you met while you was on Death Row.
Who's scheduled to be executed the next day.
It is so different.
When you there, and you talkin' to a individual
who tomorrow, he's gonna be gone.
I feel that's the difference right there.
The pressure that comes with the death penalty.
>>Natasha: Maybe I can ask Jeannie to jump
in on this too, since she's the most familiar
with California's security systems.
>>Jeannie: So Death Row in California is different
than Death Row was in Illinois.
Because they were only allowed out of their
cell one hour a day.
But in California, inmates who are on Death
Row are single celled, they're either in their
cells watching TV or they're out on an exercise
yard.
Which they're allowed to go to seven days
a week for six hours a day.
In California they have a legal team.
For life.
So they're, they receive a lot of visits.
That legal team tends to take care of them.
Sends them packages.
Christmas presents.
Make sure they have newspapers.
So they're really, they really depend on that
legal team.
And they have visiting, what else did I forget?
So, I will tell you, as the warden of San
Quentin I met every arriving, newly arrived
death row inmate in what we call classification.
And I met at least 3 inmates who had asked
for the death penalty.
Because they understood that Death Row was
an easier way of doing time in California
than serving the sentence of life without
possibility of parole.
Because in this state, when you're serving
life without possibility of parole, you're
in a maximum security prison.
You're double-celled.
You're expected to work.
You're allowed to have visiting only two days
a week.
If there's enough room in the visiting room
for you to have visitors.
Because there's a capacity on each of the
visiting rooms.
And often people will travel to prisons in
California and be turned away because the
visiting room is full.
So you can earn greater privileges if you
have life without possibility of parole, but
that is the difference.
You have to earn those privileges.
On Death Row, those things are given to you
in the state of California.
That's why it's so much more expensive to
be on Death Row in terms of the housing of
Death Row inmates.
Because you're isolated from the general population.
And either we're bringing the services to
you, or we're bringing you to the services.
So lot's of staff involved in all the processes
I just described.
>>Alan: So, one thing that I think has, uh,
focused the issue more than any other thing
in the last 10 or 15 years, is DNA.
And DNA analysis.
And the technology that has changed.
Which offers potentially irrefutable proof
of innocence.
And has cut through some of the layers of
bureaucracy.
So, you wanna talk a little bit about the
technology changes?
Since we're, there's a room, with a lot of
technologists involved.
>>Natasha: Absolutely.
So DNA is probably what's captured people's
attention and brought the issue of innocence
to the public in a way that few things have.
I'll let Jeannie actually address this.
'cause she talks about how much law enforcement
has learned from DNA.
But what's interesting is these two men, didn't
say the words DNA when they explained to you
how they were proven innocent.
In fact, their cases didn't involve DNA evidence.
>>Alan: Or any physical evidence at all.
>>Natasha: or any physical evidence.
So that's the thing, when there's no physical
evidence, it also means there's no physical
evidence to prove that you're innocent.
So in fact, DNA evidence is available in only
about 15 percent of homicide cases.
And in those cases, you can have that tool
available to tell you if this is the right
person or not.
But in fact, the majority of cases there are
no witnesses.
There is no DNA.
And the kinds of mistakes we heard about continue
to happen.
So while DNA is an incredible tool that has
been very helpful in showing us that we make
mistakes, it isn't the silver bullet that's
gonna make sure that we never make mistakes.
But I think Jeannie's perspective is also
helpful in this.
>>Jeannie: Well, what I say about DNA is that
DNA has taught us in law enforcement not to
believe everything we think.
Through DNA we found out that eyewitness testimony
is wrong more often than it's right.
We found out that people falsely confess to
crimes.
And we found out, which I think we all, we
knew all along, we just didn't wanna admit
we knew it, is that jailhouse snitches lie
most of the time.
And it's because of DNA that we have the growing
number of exonerees in the state of California
and around the country.
Because it's not, because courts and others
are not only questioning those cases where
DNA is available, but because of what we've
learned from DNA is opening the doors to other
issues where DNA is not available.
And people are taking a much more careful
look.
But, DNA is not the answer to this issue.
Replacing the death penalty is the answer.
>>Randy: I would like to say that DNA is fabulous.
It's a great safety net.
But it's such a small one.
When you have other evidence that the prosecutors
use like eyewitness testimony.
Why is it so hard for people to believe that
a jailhouse snitch, or a supposed eyewitness
to a murder, won't get up there on that stand,
for the prosecution, and lie?
They do it every day in our courts across
this country.
Many many crimes are committed right in the
courtroom every day in this country.
Because of prosecutors with their absolute
immunity and their qualified immunity clauses
that they have.
They can suborn perjury.
They can fabricate evidence.
They can hide evidence.
And all of this is what leads to wrongful
convictions.
You cannot have an irreversible punishment
in place when prosecutors have that kind of
power and are absolutely immune.
>>Alan: So we only have a few minutes here
left.
I want to focus on one particular piece of
your story.
If I can.
Which is, the moment that you found out that
you were gonna get released.
Or that you know, when you got the word that
after all these years and all the suffering
and all this pain, you know, how did it happen?
And what did you feel?
And what happened from that?
From that moment on to the moment you're reunited
from your family.
What happened?
>>Randy: Well, it was after, it was almost
16 years.
As I said, I'd lost every state appeal.
When I found out that my federal habeas corpus
opinion had come down that morning, but they
didn't know the results.
>>Alan: How did you get that news.
Who talked--?
>>Randy: My attorneys called me from out of
my cell.
And I knew it was either gonna be bad news
or it was gonna be good news.
And I set down in the captains office.
And he handed me the phone.
And she says, my attorney says "Randy, are
you settin' down?" and I said "Yes."
And says "Judge McCaskey had just granted
all 17 issues in your federal habeas corpus
position.
And ordered the state of Illinois to either
retry you or release you in 120 days."
I'm sitting there.
And I asked her, I said "Can you repeat that
for me please?"
[laughter]
Because that was the first bit of good news
that I had had in almost 17 years.
But it was shock.
It was just as shocking as the moment the
jury opened their mouth and convicted me of
this crime.
>>Nathan: Uh, as for me, I was released on
bond first.
After I got the new trial, the prosecutors
told the Illinois Supreme Court that they
could not retry me because there is no case.
If they upheld my new trial, there's no case.
So when I came back for the new trial.
I was thinkin' they was just gonna let me
go.
Soon as I went before the judge.
But the prosecutor said, "We're not bound
by what the prosecutor said to the Supreme
Court."
And they said they was gonna retry me.
And they set my bond at a million dollars.
So, Governor Ryan, the governor of Illinois
at the time, he emptied out Death Row by giving
all the prisoners on Death Row a pardon.
When he done that, one of my best friends,
Aaron Patterson came home.
He was completely exonerated.
He got his state compensation pay and he put
up 100,000 dollars and came and bond me out.
We had made a pact while we was on Death Row,
that whichever one of us get out first would
reach back and get the other.
When the guards came to my cell, and told
me "Pack up, you goin' home."
I really thought he was jokin'.
And but I started packin' up.
But I don't know why I was thinkin' he was
jokin'.
But it was real.
I packed my things up.
And I went to downstairs.
And they processed me out.
And when I got to the last gate, I had a folder
with me.
And I told the guard, "What next."
He said "Just walk out that door."
I said "Just walk out?"
He said "Yeah."
And so I walked out the door.
And as I was walking, I smelled somethin'.
That I hadn't smelled.
And when I looked up, it was a tree.
It was a tree high in the air over my head.
And I almost fell right on my face right then
on the ground.
I had to catch my balance.
I thought about what made me do that.
And there was the fact that I hadn't been
under a tree in 18 years.
And it threw me off.
But then, I walked on out.
And all my family.
The press.
It was beautiful.
>>Alan: Well great.
So I can't imagine another way, a better way
to end today than that story.
I wanna thank everyone for being here.
I think it's really been a, I feel like the
education that we get from hearing the stories
of people that are inside the system.
And understand that it's just so different
than we sometimes see.
You know.
In the media and on the television.
And other things.
And I just wanna thank you very much for bringing
your stories.
You know, to Google.
And to the people that will watch the video.
Because I think it's a very important issue.
And I think your perspectives are incredibly
important to get the word out.
And changes that we as citizens of California
can potentially make.
And I think the other thing that's important
is that California's kind of a bell ringer
for the rest of the world.
And for the United States in general.
That if California goes, if California changes
its law.
If we go with life without parole, there's
a very good chance that the rest of the nation
will follow us.
And I think the stakes are very high.
And I appreciate the time that each of you
has spent with this issue and Natasha for
leading this effort.
And I wish you the very best of luck.
So thank you everybody.
[applause]